hello it selects a chunk here with my
erstwhile friend Tom Brown that's it he
knows his name
we're here to play BuzzFeed's keep or
cancel it's a trickle cancel O'Keefe
2010 fashion Edition that's good silence
on set please
flower crowns oh okay guilty okay I did
a lot of frat flower crowns in the 2010
this year well how long ago on the 20 I
actually think I did in 2009 or even
eight Wow definitely there was a
Coachella when I had one in before Lana
Del Rey wrote songs about it yeah and
before everyone had them on their heads
Wow I didn't set the trend I was gonna
say did you set the trend do you think
she did all right but we used to walk
around these foods with for our flower
crowns on why we did a lot crafting I
didn't really have I didn't have gainful
employment okay a lot of space so I want
to cancel them now cuz okay I want to
cancel them also yeah overalls
it depends what kind of overalls if
we're talking like jumpsuit yeah I'm all
about that but for men and wood but for
women I think you can get away with
overalls so I'm gonna say cute for men
you definitely could I think they look
terrible this is so far a keep for me I
don't even know what that second option
I've worn overalls since the 2010 yeah I
haven't taken them I love the bottom and
I think a lot of the time yeah dudes
look a little bit peculiar right yeah
that's true it's a bit toddler isn't it
yeah Crocs
it's a cancel I immediately go by I see
somebody with them on yesterday and do
you know like my brand is nice guy and
your real life personality is nice guy
yeah and I was in Starbucks and if I
haven't had my coffee
I'm not Atlanta perk yes the rules and I
saw her run across you snacky green yeah
I liked her so many said I'm sorry I
disagree yeah love it
that's great okay hold that full person
yeah
chunky speech you know are they're
really they very very comfortably walked
away nica's I know we're gonna say
cancel but every now and then a turnkey
psycho I do like still and let me say
why you are incredibly told I am NOT and
so if you're around them like alright
the way don't try and act like I'm six
foot something all right
I thought it would then you wear a heel
yeah it's true
so she's often dog me so I have to wear
a tricky sneaker so I'm gonna keep mine
around okay I don't love them but I want
to keep them because I'm surrounded by
giants I am gonna cancel them I love
them in a Curb Your Enthusiasm way yeah
but beyond that like it just got to
trendy and white honestly my feet are
too big for my legs tiny sunglasses no
just like it's to over style like every
walking around not being specific it's
like we get it crop top combat pants the
tiny things perched on the edge here
like your lines and a liar just let it
go come up with your own version this
generation come up with your own version
agreed that good that's a deal breaker
for me Morpheus yeah yeah can't cancel
scrim love they don't break your hair no
justified I'm impartial like having just
given you the big like find your own
style and someone that I would like to
apologize I realize how hypocritical in
London it's kind of like a job that
people without job do I know I know I
know a lot of those people it's a thing
in Utah - it's hilarious
yeah I like it okay man buzz oh I hate a
lot even when they work why did that
happened and we let it happen
I didn't I told everyone in my life who
had one you look like
Siward i definitely slept with people
with members she different
okay I know I know no I love it I do a
little bit and it's it's back again I
hate say it is like it never goes well
yeah he's a big friend it doesn't ever
go in my opinion it's a neutral like an
animal print is often a neutral I say
the same thing I think it's navy blue of
the print wall decorations I'm over it
are you gonna break the news to them
yeah I know listen I love my castmates
to it I love it so much and I loved it
last year last year but it was last year
yeah I love athleisure not not for
everyday wear I just I I like nice
clothing to wear to the gym yeah so if
you're doing it for that yeah keep it if
you I know most of you at my brunch
space when I'm lining up waiting 25
minutes get my damn breakfast because
you chose not to go to yoga class and
you never went that yoga mats but you
always answer somewhere in that
athleisure outfit like backup like wear
and choose a different outfit and really
needs some breakfast I'm really on my
breakfast listen your saliva you go down
great can you feel the tone thank you
yeah if you give him some scrambled eggs
after that he's gonna be like I don't -
I'm bout to turn France I think never
liked it do you know I like I like the
French approach which is they hide the
fact they go to the gym because their
whole attitude is like no I don't go to
the gym like what's a gym and then
they're like taking my leggings oh I'm
into it just like why do we all have to
advertise that we're working out yeah
just just work out I don't know if you
work out or not I sometimes do and I
sometimes don't millennial pink I don't
I look pink
I don't care if it's baloney or not I
think I started with any Oh pink I wrote
a book in 2008 no use 2013 and the cover
of it was canvass millennial pink but
and then when they said look I'm serious
when they did the roundup of the year of
women and whooping came from my book
wasn't included in it and I was really
sad she was robbed no I didn't invent a
little pink I did jump on the bandwagon
I love it do you hate it now I don't
know it reminds me of like avocados on
toast in a mid-century cause I'm gonna
stop you all real quick so go on tell us
about how why you dislike going your
finger what is that yeah no here's the
thing I know I know I hate about most
people
what is it what is it like I don't love
it if it's hitting the ground you a pair
of jeans on I just do not like it I've
not owned a full yes how would I say
can't solve
I wear them and I learned it's don't a
certain way you evidence in a certain
way but most people are wearing it this
way anything is heinous okay
don't want to say counsel wedge sneakers
oh hey I really want to know more about
how you feel with so much write them at
the time I hate hate you still like it
no pass up pantsuits I love a pantsuit
strip
it's I don't know but it's still around
yeah I like it a lot I like it
let's keep that's keeping bike shorts
finally I've given this platform to tell
you this no I tried to make biker shorts
happen in the 2010s and no one was
biting and then last year suddenly
everyone wanted to wear their cycling
shorts with a baggy t-shirt and do
whatever that filter
go girls whatever well welcome to the
party I'm afraid you're a bit late in
your own you Oreo prayer no I quite like
them we made the I like them I like them
what I think they're very exclusive it's
really unfair like most people can't let
them feel good about themselves but
weirdly I think they're cozy chunky
thighs you get chafing I can sort of
solve that problem because you're not
you're like things don't rub together we
should have it no I'm not gonna be done
shame it ok fit that's it
thanks for watching I'm sorry for the
incendiary comments and language make
sure you watch next in fashion it's
available now on Netflix globally you're
gonna love our promise
[Music]